[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren feld der nach dem top der
schlagzeilen nächsten 15 minuten wenn
wir über intensivbetten schwindel markus
söder die fühlte und die olympischen
spiele sprechen meine gäste heute abend
der informatiker und autor tom larsen
der mit seinem buch die intensiv mafia
von den hirten der pandemie und ihren
propheten aktuell die bestsellerlisten
stürmt es wird spannend und ein gast der
übrigens von ihnen unseren zuschauern
empfohlen wurde dementsprechend mal
wieder eine gäste empfehlung ich bin
sehr gespannt neben ihnen der leiter der
bild parlamentsredaktion ralf schuler
kaum ein tolles in der hauptkammer
unserer demokratie den bundestag so gut
vernetzt pr an meiner seite der
stellvertretende bild chefredakteur paul
ronzheimer
2021 für sein reporter einsatz in
afghanistan alle journalisten preise
verdient gehabt hätte last but not least
unser stammgast béla anda ehemaliger
regierungssprecher und
kommunikationsexperte sein linkedin
motto was mir wahnsinnig gut gefällt du
kannst vor gericht gewinnen aber in der
öffentlichkeit verlieren also los mein
name ist nähmaschine und ich freue mich
sehr die runde heute eröffnen zu dürfen
mein thema heute abend ist markus söder
der bayerische ministerpräsident fordert
jetzt wird es spannend konsequente
öffnung schritte söder schlägt vor zitat
mit einer fft zwei maske können wir auf
den zweig regel im handel verzichten man
hält sich nur kurz in geschäften auf das
bayerische verwaltungsgericht hatte die
zweijährigen einzelhandel kürzlich
gekippt für seine verhältnisse bei
markus söder trotzdem ein gewagter
vorstoß quasi von team vorsicht zu team
mutig für mich schon jetzt der wanne des
jahres man möchte sogar am liebsten
zurufen mensch markus geht doch nina
also ich bin ja ein bisschen überrascht
dass dir das schon reicht also ich meine
markus söder sagt masken müssen bleiben
das
2g abschaffung die jetzt schon reicht um
markus söder zu sagen mensch ganz ganz
toll die wahrheit ist doch nur eine er
hat angst dass er seine wahl verliert
und er ist in panik geraten ja ich finde
es auch gut dass er sich so wandelt ein
bisschen ich habe es heute auch in die
richtung kommentiert bei bild aber
dennoch muss man doch sagen wenn wir um
uns herum schauen und jetzt auf den
nächsten freedom day zb in schweden
schauen oder die entwicklung diese
norwegen dänemark und so weiter gibt
dann ist das ziemlich weh jaaa powell
und es ist ja nicht so ganz über nacht
gekommen sondern markus söder ist
natürlich jemand der seine wechsel dies
ja auch schon mal häufiger gibt von dem
einen extrem ins andere doch klug
intoniert und vorbereitet untersatz teil
einer langen strategie darstellt er kann
aus dem weihnachtsurlaub und hat gesagt
er hat lange nachgedacht hat überlegt
und hat gesagt dass er etwas ändern muss
weil da natürlich gesehen hat gerade aus
oberbayern der gab es massiven druck auf
und seine csu leute gesagt nur das
reicht uns jetzt alles und man muss
einen weg heraus finden aus dieser für
viele einschränkenden lager und deswegen
hatte diese neuen maßnahmen jetzt
präsentiert übrigens maßnahmen die in
anderen bundesländern wie niedersachsen
per gesicht per gericht schon nicht mehr
so sind und nicht mehr angewendet werden
also etwas in einen zustand überführt
was schon anderswo gilt aber man muss
natürlich auch mal sagen was wollen wir
denn für politiker die einfach erotisch
das durchziehen was wir einmal
angefangen haben oder darf man auch
dazulernen insofern ist ein
instinktpolitiker wie söder immer
natürlich irgendwie auch mit einem rohr
an der masse und der wahlkampf ist schon
angesprochen worden man darf nicht
vergessen dass gerade die csu
eine ganz klare stammtisch partei ist
die kreisversammlung die ortsversammlung
fast alles findet in stammtischen statt
und wenn jetzt die wirtshäuser noch
länger zu bleiben mal abgesehen von der
gastronomie wirtschaft die auch an
gebäuden ist in bayern dann hätte das
massive auswirkungen gerade auch auf die
mobilisierung an der csu-basis das darf
man auch nicht ganz vergessen also es
ist einerseits rational andererseits
kennen wir markus söder natürlich als
jemanden der so viele überzeugung hat
dass er sie nacheinander der
öffentlichkeit präsentieren muss also
gerade noch die fixe in den amtsstuben
aufgehängt dann bäume umarmt und
team vorsicht jetzt team mut ich also da
geht noch was also mensch markus kann
ich jetzt noch nicht unterstützen da
warten wir erst mal noch mal ab ich bin
der festen überzeugung wir haben ganz
viele schlimme sachen gesehen wo wir
alle gedacht haben so das ist jetzt aber
schon über die grenze rüber von herrn
söder und ich möchte da nur daran
erinnern dass natürlich in gerade in
dieser corona zeit wo es um maßnahmen ja
oder nein geht da hat herr söder auch
teilweise marketingmaßnahmen gemacht die
ich sehr schlimm fand zum beispiel die
verlegung von 23 patienten aus rottal
inn oder aus der ecke da unten das ist
ja schon sehr kritisch wenn man das den
menschen zeigt die menschen kriegen
einst und jetzt auf einmal soll es
heißen und keine angst mehr und ich muss
dazu sagen ich komme ja von den zahlen
und ich sehe diese dinge ja wenn 23
patienten verlegt werden aus
intensivstation auch wenn es so wie
patienten sind so ist es doch so dass in
deutschland 194 1000 patienten auf
intensivstationen jedes jahr verlegt
werden denn andere intensivstation also
23 werden mit presse begleitet weil sie
cupid patienten sind und was ist mit den
anderen
194.000 ja aber wenn sie von den zahlen
her kommen ich wohne ja auch in bayern
und bayern ist es ja so dass die
ähnliche incidence werte hatten wie
sachsen oder thüringen lange zeit und
jetzt immer noch der kreis mit den
meisten infektionen im moment und mit
den höchsten inzidenz bis dahin ganz
deutschland also nahe münchen der
landkreis münchen führt ebersberg sind
alles führende über den in diesem sinne
regionen und wir kommen ja aus einer
phase wo für uns diese zahl denn diese
incident ziehen höchst bedrohlich waren
ich habe im vorletzten sommer eine
veranstaltung organisiert haben wir
absagen müssen weil die inzidenz zeit
bei 3 lag jetzt liegt sie zum teil über
2100 kann man sagen wie eure waren wir
damals aber dass sich die situation und
deswegen bin ich da so ein bisschen auch
geben sie in hösel das
erstaunlicherweise für verständnis zu
sagen dass es da eine gewisse panik oder
aufgeregtheit gab und eben team vorsicht
also haltet aber es war nicht so dass
ich mich vor sicht sondern eben auch
team panik also ich erinnere mich wenn
er in ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gesagt haben gut gottes willen jeden tag
den wir hier erleben stürzt ein flugzeug
ab und wie viele menschen sterben also
das habe ich dann schon als panikmache
ein bisschen empfunden und darüber
hinaus muss man sagen markus söder hat
seine politik eben sehr sehr spät jetzt
angepasst es gab ja schon länger die
analyse dass nikon eben nicht so schlimm
ist wie immer behauptet wurde und dass
eben weniger menschen in
intensivstationen sind und wenn ich mir
november/dezember anschaue wie markus so
dass ich dann noch geäußert hat da muss
ihm wohl irgendwie
die weihnachtsbeleuchtung gekommen seien
oder die neujahrs erleuchtung ich weiß
es nicht so viel anders als im dezember
sieht es nämlich eigentlich gar nicht
aus aber was mich noch viel mehr fuchs
ist die tatsache dass bayern riesen
incidence werte hatte und die begründung
ständig wechselten warum das so ist zum
teil wurde ist auf die grenze geschoben
wenn das die grenze gewesen wäre hätte
man die grenzen dicht machen müssen dass
das neue studie sagt grenzen dicht
machen bringt gar nichts egal wenn ich
diese kausalität hersteller muss ich
dann auch so handeln nein die grenzen
getrieben wurden nicht aufmacht dann
hieß es wieder ja es sind die migranten
die vom balkan zurückkommen es gab mal
einen spektakulären fallen dingolfing im
bmw werk
das werk lag stand nahezu still weise
auf einen schlag glaube ich 500 leute
mit mit corona zurück kamen aber wir
wissen es bis heute nicht und was ist
denn das für ein wesen das wichtigste
land in der europäischen union und wir
kriegen einfach eine krankheit zumindest
wissentlich nicht durchdrungen und die
ursachen zu erforschen das bei mir
einfach nicht in den kopf und ich ist es
der datenschutz ist es die mangelnde
erhebung ist es einfach mentales
unvermögen sind wir zu bescheuert woran
liegt also ich würde sagen ist es dass
datenerhebung problem das wird ja auch
schon von vielen anderen professoren
professor anthes zum beispiel der hat
sich dazu ja schon vielfach geäußert ich
glaube auch professor stöhr hat sich
dazu geäußert also ich kann ihnen nur
sagen wenn wir über incidents
entsprechen haben wir ein riesiges
problem weil instanzen haben nichts mit
erkrankung zu tun ich will ihnen das mal
an einem beispiel veranschaulicht
erkenntnis die aber ist ja mal so nicht
von anfang an gegeben oder doch die
hätte sein können ja weil wir haben in
2020 und 20 21 zum glück und das freut
mich auch dass wir die daten haben die
krankenhaus abrechnungsdaten für das
letzte quartal als 20 21 gekriegt und
man gibt dort einfach nur mal ein wie
viele leute von denen die als corona
hospitalisiert wurden als co sieht
kranke hatten dann gar keine symptome
das kann man jetzt rausfinden 70.000
fans das ist eine ihre zahl ist das
heißt also wir haben instanzen wir haben
leute die ins krankenhaus gehen also
eine hospitalisierung und das ergebnis
daraus ist wie alle denken das ist irre
voll und es ist gar nicht so es sind
70.000 die wir mit ganz einfachen
codierungen herausfinden weil die fälle
werden hier am ende wenn jemand dann
raus ist oder vielleicht gehen sie da
kommt ja auch
da kommen wir später aber mich
interessiert noch ein letztes mal zu
herr söder reif und pauli ab die ja auch
beide oft erlebt wie ist er denn jetzt
so als zufall so stimmt meint dass erst
jetzt eingesehen hat oder ist ja
eigentlich so ein wahlkämpfer der jetzt
einfach merkt der wind weht einfach
wirklich anders ich muss den stimmen
hinter hat einfach ein wahnsinnig gutes
gespür dafür was im land abgeht was aus
seiner eigenen basis kommt was
verkaufbar ist etwas nicht verkaufbar
ist und natürlich hat er auch ein stab
von mitarbeitern die in bezahlen
aufbereiten und die zahlen mit denen in
der öffentlichkeit operiert wird sind ja
aus man sich gar nicht vorstellen gar
nicht die das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen es ist auch ein ster hat
keine zahlen für einen der weiß keine
einzige zahl doch er weiß zum beispiel
dass wenn der anstieg nicht an ergänzen
zum beispiel von der verdienst wenn der
anstieg oder von der hospitalisierung
wenn der sich nicht erhöht das dann
eigentlich schon ein punkt erreicht ist
das heißt man hat das wissen dass es da
etwas abflacht ob man dann politisch den
schluss daraus zieht jetzt auch schon zu
öffnen oder ob man sagt okay es läuft
ganz gut die werte umfrage bei unfall
sympathie sind eigentlich ganz gut
warten wir noch ein bisschen das gefühl
der leute ist noch nicht so dass es
entspannt ist dann bedient lieber das
gefühl auch das spielt immer mit einer
rolle also wir dürfen nicht uns
vorstellen dass corona ein
wissenschaftliches objekt und die
politik plötzlich nicht mehr politisch
agiert das tut sie sehr wohl na ja also
es sind ja grundsatzfragen weil sie ja
gefragt haben der markus söder und so
weiter welche welche basis hat da ist er
jetzt irgendwie jemand der ein guter
player ist in dieser corona frage und
ich bin der meinung dass er das nicht
ist der spielt für die anderen
ministerpräsidenten mit kann man
natürlich auch bei mir nachlesen wie ich
jetzt gar nicht wie viel darüber
sprechen aber für mich ist das was ich
hier sehe
wissenschaftlich mit sicherheit nicht
begründbar von den zahlen her kann ich
das nicht sehen und wenn wir nur über
incidents reden dann müssen ja
eigentlich erstmal grundsatzfragen
geklärt werden
das sind so einfache fragen das macht ja
gar keiner mehr wenn wir uns gegenseitig
treffen und einer von uns hat das in
sich und er überträgt das symptomlos an
den anderen dann muss noch geklärt
werden kann der andere davon überhaupt
schwer krank werden das habe ich das
robert-koch-institut gefragt und
deswegen die wissen das alle nicht und
dann hat das robert koch institut im
dezember 20 habe ich das gehirn wird
darüber haben wir gar keine daten dann
habe ich noch mal im april 2021 gefragt
darüber haben wir immer noch keine daten
gestern habe ich noch mal nachgefragt
heute hat mir vor glasmacher geantwortet
es tut mir leid lesen wir haben immer
noch keine daten wir wissen gar nicht ob
jemand der einen anderen symptomlos
ansteckt ob er überhaupt bei dem anderen
die schwere krankheit auslösen kann das
wissen die nicht das erheben die auch
nicht schreiben sie sogar unten noch
drunter was folgern sie denn darauf sich
das ist sicherlich das jetzt noch mal
ich meinte sie ich man kriegt immer sehr
viel geht wenn man menschen wie ihnen
widerspricht weil eine große community
natürlich ihnen folgt und an ihnen an
der glan doch und innen lippen hängt und
jede kritik an äußerungen dieser art
oder so ist immer im grunde ist dieses
teufel 2 viele menschen ihnen glauben
schenkt und ist ja auch toll sind eine
neue erkenntnisse nur politik agiert ja
so nicht politik kann nicht jedes mal
wenn sie sie hat ist gut wir wissen über
die lage in den gesundheits intensiven
darüber sichtlich berichtet das gibt zum
teil noch händisch ihre faxe ausfüllen
oder daten gab es jetzt in der welt ein
bericht wieder händisch übertragen die
ihnen digital übermittelt worden sind so
ist die lage immer noch aber was folgt
den raus politik muss auf den moment
reagieren und ich war sehr froh sage ich
dass er so da tatsächlich da etwas
offensiver reagiert hat in der phase wo
die inzidenz hoch waren wo nicht klar
war wie sie sagen ob es diese
übertragung gibt und welche folgen das
hat um dem fall ich bin etwas nicht klar
ist war ich am anfang auch er für den
offensiveren kurs als zu sagen lass mal
eben laufen würde war ja weiter damit
jeder seine zeit heute hat bleiben wir
jetzt direkt bei dir bela es gibt ja
noch ein anderes thema was deutschland
bewegt außerhalb der datenerhebung das
ist die impfpflicht das ist die
impfpflicht und ja ich habe mich
aufgeregt in dem zusammenhang über
christian drosten auch das tut man nicht
in deutschland bei christian drosten ist
hier sozusagen ein säulenheiliger und
jeder der in kritisiert ist auch wissen
ob zumindest in einer anderen community
ich mache es trotzdem denn christian
drosten hast jetzt einblick gegeben wie
er sich den besten von corona vorstellt
wahrscheinlich hatte lange geforscht um
das herauszufinden aber er hat gesagt
und ich zitiere hier die ideale
immunisierung ist dass man eine
vollständige immunisierung hat also drei
dosen gerümpft geimpft und gross tat und
sich dann zitat geht weiter erstmalig
und auch zweit malik und tritt malik mit
dem virus infiziert also übersetzt heißt
das einmal zweimal dreimal impfen danach
einmal zweimal dreimal infizieren dann
bin ich bestmöglich geschützt wer das
durchgemacht hat so professor draußen
weiter seien wahrscheinlich über jahre
immun und werde sich dann nicht mehr
infizieren dabei die stimme die
intensität der infektion mit wie
anhaltende impfschutz sein kann
die biologin sandra zeck die wir gerade
gesehen haben hat in ihrem podcast
gesagt man soll die folgen von long
goodbye unicom nicht unterschätzen also
im grunde das gegenteil gesagt als er
ich finde christian drosten hat mit
seinen äußerungen impft bewegungen
echten tort angetan denn es geht ja um
millionen menschen die bisher noch nicht
geimpft sind die wir überzeugen wollen
oder dahin bringen wollen mit der
impfpflicht sich impfen zu lassen damit
wir alle hier rauskommen aus dieser
zweig plus oder zweig regelungen aus dem
mini lockdown odermatt lockerheit in der
gerade abend aber wie will ich den
menschen und das muss ich ja tun
nahebringen dass eine impfung für sie
richtig ist dass die impfpflicht richtig
ist wenn mir der oberste virologe sagt
also im grunde um euch richtig zu
schützen müsst ihr euch drei mal impfen
dreimal infizieren und dann wird die
impfung auf dauer deswegen muss ich
sagen aus dieser geschichte bin ich
jetzt raus eine impfpflicht und den sinn
dafür kann ich nach diesen äußerungen
nicht mehr
das muss ich leider unterstützen weil
drosten jemand ist er schon sehr früh zu
sehen gewesen ist er hat damals am 29
januar 2020 metern thaddäus in einem
sehr interessanten interview gesessen
also ich fand das extrem spannend weil
er auch erklärt hat dass man diese
respiratorischen erkrankungen gekommen
dass man immer versucht sie zunächst
einmal aufzuhalten damit ist die
älteren und schwächeren eben später
trifft und damit man das nicht
überlastet aber es gelingt nie dass es
sozusagen so von ihm gesichert ist
wissen an tadeusz übergeben worden
öffentlich in einem interview und das
hat sich ja sehr geändert also diese
ganze geschichte hat sich sehr geändert
und da frage ich mich natürlich nach dem
vertrauen das sich in jemanden haben der
uns dann irgendwie eine impfpflicht
geschert und dann kann ich nur sagen
okay dann gucke ich mal zurück zu den
zahlen haben die anderen das gemacht und
ich hoffe ich langweilig ein wenig über
zahlen reden aber auch da müssen wir
natürlich immer gucken gibt es und das
hatten sie gestern im thema mit der lisa
fitz gibt es im nebenwirkungen oder
schwere impfnebenwirkungen die man
betrachten muss und die krankenhausdaten
und ich will da gar nicht die großen
zahlen nennen die ich hier jetzt stehen
habe und ich möchte auch frau fekter in
keiner form aber ich kann ihnen sagen
dass ich denke dass es richtig nicht
richtig ist jetzt eine impfpflicht
einzuführen bevor man das nicht alles
konkret überprüft hat die daten liegen
vor sinnvoll ist allein gegen die
impfpflicht bei wie siehst du das ich
habe vor allem ein problem mit unserem
recht habe politikern es ist so eine
große rechthaberei die jetzt stattfindet
alle sehen zahlen alle sehen was gerade
passiert nämlich dass das ursprüngliche
ziel was man mal hatte nicht aufgeht da
ging es ja mal darum man wolle die
ansteckung verhindern dann ging es darum
schwere erkrankungen zu verhindern jetzt
und übernächste über übernächste
erkrankung zu verhindert und damit
keiner mehr schwer krank die wahrheit
ist doch dass diejenigen die die
impfpflicht von anfang an kritisiert
haben zumindest die allgemeine
impfpflicht recht haben und diejenigen
die uns erzählt haben dass das der
richtige weg ist falsch liegen so was
sollte daraus hervorgehen olaf scholz
und die leute um ihn herum sollten
endlich mal aufwachen olaf scholz hat
übrigens im rating ein rekordergebnis
nicht eingefahren sondern wurde
abgestuft also das glaube ich um über
fast zweistellig hatte eine
sympathiewerten verloren und ich glaube
das liegt auch daran dass man einfach
stur an einer politik festhalten will
die von der realität überholt worden ist
weil die politiker sich heutzutage nicht
mehr trauen zu sagen mensch wir haben da
einen fehler gemacht da gibt es neue
erkenntnisse dass erstaunlich ist ja das
aber bei der andere wer nämlich jetzt
mal christian lindner ist es nämlich der
ja vor der wahl gesagt hat auf gar
keinen fall machen wir das mit der
impfpflicht und da ging es ganz einfach
zu sagen jetzt machen wir erst warum
kann man denn jetzt nicht sagen ja jetzt
sehen wir es wieder so wie vor der wahl
aber jetzt einfach nicht so böse du bist
doch auf einem sehr guten weg bis drei
mal geimpft es war einmal genießen
0,83 hast du schon halsbereich und der
macht war ich ein bisschen sauer weil
ich versuche seit zwei jahren mich nicht
anzustecken und merkt jetzt ist der
falsche weg das ist bitter also
vielleicht hätte ich doch viel mehr
corona partys feiern müssen oder
ähnliches hat er ist stelle ich mich
nicht bei einer corona park
ich habe einiges hingeflogen war
angefangen hat nichts geholfen ganz
schlimm bittere rückschläge sind
vielleicht gibt es bald immunisierung
partys bilder aber es geht euch doch
auch so es wirkt widersinnig impfpflicht
zu fordern auf der einen seite die
menschen die noch skeptisch sind darum
geht es ja bei den ecken pflicht
diejenigen die skeptisch sind es geht ja
nicht nur darum menschen zu zwingen sich
impfen zu lassen dann das sagen hier
gibt es einen brief von skeptikern oder
menschenliebe nicht erreicht haben aus
welchen gründen auch immer und die
wollen wir durch eine impfpflicht dahin
bringen dass sich mehr menschen
tatsächlich auch impfen dass das ist ja
eigentlich das ziel aber die dieses ziel
höre ich doch jetzt völlig aus wenn ich
sage wer richtig gut geimpft bist du nur
wenn du dich drei mal impfen ist drei
mal infiziert und dann auf jahre hinaus
heißt ja auch nicht endgültig geschützt
ich kenne ja nicht verstehen und
christian drosten überhaupt noch zu hört
also dieser podcast den ja alle
deutschen am anfang der kroner pandemie
gehört haben also warum
es hat sich doch alles verändert und
überschlagen und bestimmte dinge
gestimmte menschen haben auch angst ich
glaube das ist ein ganz ganz großer
punkt viele menschen haben nach wie vor
ganz große angst und viele menschen
halten auch die omikron variante einfach
noch nicht für sicher und ich glaube die
angst der menschen und die haben in
london war ich da wurde ich gefragt
warum eigentlich auch in der
gesellschaft in den medien so viel panik
geschürt wurde in england hätte man mehr
verschiedene standpunkte von anfang an
gehabt und ich glaube das wird ganz
lange dauern vor allem die panik aus der
gesellschaft zu kriegen gab es dass er
interessante was wir gesehen haben in
dieser corona pandemie ist die
unterschiedlichen mentalitäten mit den
unterschiedlichen länder daran gegangen
sind das war das absolut faszinierend
ich war beim g 7 gipfel im juni letzten
jahres in cornwall und da musste bayern
oder ja für alle die es noch nicht
wussten ja ein teil 1 teil englands und
der musste bei region sind gerade den
eigentlich angesetzten frieden day
wieder einsammeln und weil die zahlen
etwas nach oben ging und das obwohl also
noch ein bisschen verlängert das führt
aber nicht dazu dass man jetzt die papst
geschlossen hat also man
selbstverständlich hat mal weiter
draußen gesessen und die briten denn wie
gesagt ja gut aber das müssen wir jetzt
länger machen aber wir stellen uns
deshalb unser lebensstil nicht um die
dänen haben es ähnlich wir haben wir
haben alles gemacht was man von ihnen
verlangt hat sie haben sich auch nicht
impfen lassen aber jetzt trotz hoher
inzidenz und machen sie wieder auf die
deutschen sind da immer sehr stark regel
fixiert sagt kommt immer wieder
die heimspiele abstand hat vielleicht
auch geholfen kurzfristig aber bei dem
thema impfpflicht finde ich dann muss
bitte die regierung wenn sie ernsthaft
dafür votiert ich bin gegen eine
impfpflicht bin sehr fürs impfen chart
nix aber da muss die regierung bitte
schön sagen was ist eigentlich der
effekt dieses impfen also haben wir uns
auch mal die gründungs grundlage an also
der expertenrat ist ja so zu seite der
ethikrat ist ja sozusagen das
expertengremium für die bundesregierung
wenn sie sich mit einer impfpflicht
beschäftigen da muss es ja eine sehr
hohe begründung last geben damit man das
überhaupt zwangsweise oder pflicht artig
mit bußgeldern oder so was wir vor uns
sehen dass man das begründen kann und
der einzige oder das gremium ist der
ethikrat und wenn man sich das anguckt
dann ist das ja anders als bei masern
mama dann war das ja früher auch schon
so dass es da eine impfpflicht gegeben
hat die man begründet hat aber mit dem
fremdschutz und dass diese ad-hoc
stellungnahme des ethikrates habe ich
mir genau durchgelesen und ich habe
festgestellt die einzige begründung
warum eine impfpflicht zurzeit ist und
vielleicht weil das jetzt noch nicht so
bekannt aber die einzige begründung ist
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
zu verändern und da kommen wir gleich
noch zu aber da habe ich jetzt
eigentlich ganz weiten bei der
allgemeinen kriegsheim uns hier sehr
einer meinung am tisch zu sein weil wie
siehst du die berufsbezogene impfpflicht
per wlan
ja wie gesagt eben pflicht macht für
mich sinn und eine berufsbezogene
impfpflicht ebenso wie bisher weil weil
man davon ausgehen musste dass
diejenigen die zu tun haben mit
besonders ungeschützt menschen besonders
kranken und dergleichen hier einen
besonderen schutz gewährleisten müssen
auch in der frage in der tatsache
geschuldet dass sie geimpft sind also
wenn ich als pfleger jemanden behandelt
der vielleicht herzkrank ist der
aufgrund von schwächen sich nicht impfen
lassen können dann muss ich als
krankenhaus und auch als fürsorge aus
fürsorgepflicht davon ausgehen müssen
dass derjenige eben
nicht ansteckend ist wir wissen nun auch
als geimpfter kann ich ansteckend sein
ich kann mich infizieren ich kann
ansteckend sein und nach der lehre jetzt
von der osten sollte ich drei mal
geimpft und drei mal infiziert sein
damit ich eben möglichst gut geschützt
und vielleicht auch das müssen die
zahlen belegen aber am wenigsten klar
wenn ich als geimpfter es trotzdem
weiter tragen kann dann kann ich das als
pfleger doch genau an diese schutzengel
weitergeben größter und dann frage ich
mich was die was die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht dann bringen soll
also ich selbst schütze mich nicht ich
schütze aber links auch den pflegen zu
pflegenden patienten nicht gut ich habe
einen milderen verlauf das ist
sicherlich sehr schön aber das schutz
argument also die menschen die andere
pflegen sollen sich impfen lassen wenn
sie es dann trotz der impfung
weitergeben und möglicherweise jemand
mit vorerkrankungen dann stirbt dann
habe ich das ziel gar nicht ich möchte
einfach von der politik die mir eine
maßnahme auferlegt wissen was ist das
ziel damit ich die politik hinterher
daran messen kann ob das ziel erreicht
wird ob es dass der ob die maßnahme
zwingend war ob sie angemessen war und
ob sie zu dem ziel geführt hat wenn dass
die politik gar nicht definieren kann
dann kann ich nicht irgendeine pflicht
einfach ausgeben und so lange wir
probieren das mal sehen ob es klappt
aber wissen wir auch nicht bleiben beim
impfen und geben weiter an alzheimer ja
ich habe das gefühl dass ich in einem
dauerhaften albtraum bilden ich träume
am anfang hat man mir gesagt ein pieks
ja ja das reicht also einmal impfen dann
hieß es der zweite der muss schon sein
damit ist wirklich wirklich sicher ist
und dann hat man lange wir hatten ein
nein also dritter vielleicht israel
testet das aber bei uns nicht und dann
doch der dritte pix und jetzt
38 centers reicht leider nicht aus liebe
freunde in deutschland und überall die
stiko sagt jetzt wir brauchen vier
obwohl weil sowohl karl lauterbach der
gesundheitsminister noch im januar
gesagt hast drei reichen ich kann sagen
als jemand der mittlerweile zweimal
ansteckten ist mitbewohner und gemustert
also dreifach geimpft ist es ein
absoluter horror wenn ich jetzt sage
hier noch weiter drei punkten und 4 x 56
x und dann brauche ich vielleicht auch
noch mal wie wir von herrn thorsten
gehört haben weitere ansteckung also
witz beiseite das macht alles überhaupt
keinen sinn mehr diese politik ist nicht
mehr logisch und interessanterweise
führt sich auch diese eben pflicht über
die wir gerade gesprochen haben noch
mehr ad absurdum weil vorher dieses in
der debatte nämlich ist braucht die drei
impfung und wenn wir jetzt über viel
sprechen dann weiß ja niemand was in den
nächsten wochen monaten da auf uns
zukommt und vor allem sagen experten
dass wir gar nicht wissen ob dann dieser
impfstoff wirklich wirkt und ob das
nutzen weil es wirklich ausgeglichen er
prallt ich stimme dir natürlich zu mit
einer kleinen stelle mit einem kleinen
unterschied ich finde ja das musst du
nur einstelligen zweimal ich bin auch
ich war noch nie infiziert nein das muss
ich wirklich sagen und ich verstehe gar
nicht warum nicht ich bin ja immer sehr
am reisen gewesen aber gut aber sie war
eigentlich sagen will ist ich bin dafür
jeder kann sicher impfen also wenn sich
jemand sicherer fühlt mit der firma der
fünf jahre soll ist völlig in ordnung
auch genau so wie zum beispiel auch in
unserer redaktion manche tragen im
großraumbüro maske ich tu's nicht weiß
auf völlig in ordnung und deswegen auch
mit der impfung ich finde einfach die
indirekte im pflichten muss enden das
heißt dieses nur ein mensch mit diesem
corona pass darf dinge machen das muss
für mich enden die indirekte im
pflichten muss enden auch in england
habe ich nicht ein einziges mal mein
kroner zertifikat am ganzen wochenende
vor gezeigt aber wenn jemand den vierten
von fünf euro ab so dass muss nur einmal
auf ja ich bin überhaupt nicht dagegen
dass die menschen sich freiwillig impfen
lassen wie gesagt ich habe mich ja auch
impfen und bin dann trotzdem zweimal
erkrankt
dennoch ist es so dass ich finde wenn
die stiko etwas sagt hatte schon so ein
bisschen fast gesetzes mäßiger stimmt
dabei aber es ist auch eine frage wird
finde ich jedenfalls von vertrauen also
ich finde wenn man irgendwie eine
neuartige sache in sich hinein früher
war das nicht so tetanus umso mehr
machen und hp oder auch nicht aber es
ist eine sache von vertrauen und ich
finde wir haben über markus söder
gesprochen mensch markus und stellen
fest dass das wechselt die meinung
wechselt jeden tag und bei solchen
widersprüchlichkeiten muss ich mich
natürlich fragen ist das vertrauen bei
den menschen die sie angesprochen haben
ist dieses vertrauen überhaupt da wie
stellen politiker überhaupt vertrauen
her für so eine idee eine maßnahme um
eine pandemie zu bekämpfen die idee ist
ja wahrscheinlich gut aber es ist
offensichtlich nicht genug vertrauen da
und das ist verspielt worden und ich
würde sagen eine sache die vielleicht zu
der vierten impfung oder der fünften
sechsten siebten passt ist die frage wir
haben doch studien gemacht vorher und
wieso wussten wir nicht aus den studien
dass nach drei monaten schon ende ist
gelände ist es nicht überprüft worden
das verstehe ich nicht und das sind ja
so vertrauensfragen die man sich stellt
wenn man dann sagt ich gucke jetzt okay
wir wussten es nicht okay jetzt machen
wir drei mal 45 mal und das darum geht
es ja eigentlich vertrauen verspielt ist
ein gutes stichwort ja in ein
wesentlicher punkt in dem was du
genanntes paulis ja auch die
kommunikation und glaube da ist ein
wesentlicher fehler bis heute wird
gemacht von politikern die glauben keine
schwäche eingestehen zu dürfen keine
fehler zuzugeben weil es dann sofort bei
ihnen landet und sie sich dadurch
angreifbar machen es hat niemand du hast
recht hier hat uns gesagt ein pieks zwei
picks reichen und dann den eindruck
zumindest vermittelt gestützt auf
experten das reicht fürs leben war ja
erst dahinter auf gott sei dank gibt es
die impfung da wir sind alle raus
diejenigen die sich impfen lassen dann
kam auf einmal der hinweis auf dem
booster dann jetzt der vierte pix und
die frage der haltbarkeit impfung der
dauer es hat aber nie jemanden in
verantwortung stehend gesagt dass man es
euch damals erzählt zwei impfungen
reichen aus jetzt müssen wir zu bestehen
die erkenntnisse sind einfach anders
also diesen schritt hat es von keinem
noch nicht mehr auf herr lauterbach
gegeben es wurde wenn überhaupt nur
positiv kommuniziert gesagt der dritte
hilft ganz besonders der vierte ist da
auf einmal ist die zeitspanne der
impfungen weg oder geschrumpft oder
dergleichen aber mich als bürger hat nie
jemand mitgenommen und deswegen gibt es
diese enorme diskrepanz zwischen dem was
man gesagt worden ist und zu dem was ich
jetzt sagen wir okay was kommt denn
jetzt wird die nächste hattrick bilde
gewesen hätte ja aus dem hofer ich habe
das ein ganz wichtiger punkt die politik
kommt einfach aus dem doktor allwissend
modus nicht raus den sie sonst gerne hat
bei atomausstieges gesundheitsreformen
und anderen rentenreformen wo sie immer
ganz genau weiß dass das segensreiche
jetzt was ihr gerade beschließt obwohl
wir in einer an dem wir uns befinden wo
eigentlich selbst die wissenschaftler
jeden tag tastend sich voran bewegt
haben und das ist glaube ich das große
problem dass man die fuß gehabt habe ich
mal gesagt die menschen wissen wenig
aber sie ahnen meistens richtig den
eindruck hatte also so genau wissen dies
aber eigentlich auch nicht und dann
kommt noch hinzu dass man witzigerweise
sobald eine neue variante entdeckt
worden ist gab es schon studiendesign
ganz schlimm die ist noch schlimmer wenn
man da nicht aufpassen dass also wo man
sich fragt komisch wir haben
über die wirkung und impfstoffen haben
jetzt mal jahre danach noch gut also
vielleicht brauchen wir doch noch mal 4
aber wir mussten innerhalb von zwei
wochen dass omikron eine wand wird und
da denken die leute irgendwie auch im
jahr das gesellt sahen also das
schlechte wissen sie sehr schnell und
angeblich auch ganz sicher und bei dem
anderen ist es ganz seltsam nun ist es
ja nichts neues dass man impfungen gibt
es bei anderen auch selbst bei tollwut
oder muss man auf frischen nach einigen
jahren nur man muss es einfach dann auch
so kommunizieren wie man es weiß sonst
hat man so ein bisschen diese in diesen
fischmarkt effekt mensch drei impfungen
vier nennen mich verrückt ich habe noch
einen
noch einmal unten auf 2
das wirkt dann etwas unernst also im
primär nichts wenn wir jetzt mal und
zwei gurken geben werden sie die leute
eben viele ja gut ich meine die
bratwurstbude hätte ich jetzt schon vier
beisammen ich
möchte da jetzt nicht weiter darauf
eingehen aber ich finde es gibt auch den
fall dass sich jemand 20 mal hat impfen
lassen für
da macht man schon sagen ich weiß nicht
wie weiter impfpass reicht wie viel zeit
seiten drin sind aber vielleicht wollte
man auch zum impfen mit der nähmaschine
übergehen und ordnung dann hat man so
eine perforierte aber gut vielleicht
muss man sich mit mit herzchen drüber
weg wetten ja also ich habe wie gesagt
ich habe dazu ihr das gesagt und ich
finde das auch sehr spannend es ist ja
auch eine spannende zeit in der wir uns
jetzt gerade bewegen und die
entscheidung ändern sich ja jeden tag
man wacht morgens auf und stellt fest
dass es mal wieder eine andere idee im
gange und solange das so ist und da
haben wir uns ja gerade so unterhalten
so lange es kein ausreichendes
kommunikatives mittel gibt mit den
menschen zu sprechen wird es nix und es
wird ja eigentlich immer eher radikaler
von einer politik die die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen die laufen auf der
straße rum und dann wird von denen
geschimpft die sah ja aber ihr müsst
euch ja impfen lassen und da kann ich
nur sagen das ist ja keine kommunikation
das ist ja gar nichts lassen sie jetzt
informatiker der auch die zahlen fest im
blick hat wie kommen wir aus der
pandemie heraus dass kann ich sagen da
habe ich überhaupt gar keine idee also
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich mir die zahlen
anguckt dann muss ich auch schon sehr
suchen um jetzt noch auf dem krankenhaus
irgendwelche sachen zu finden da kommen
wir ja gleich zu also wir haben ja keine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
gehabt sondern wir können ja jetzt
zahlen vergleiche anstellen wir können
gucken wie wir es im 2009 10 20 21 und
wenn ich ihnen das sage das kann ich
jetzt hier heute nicht im detail dazu
kann man sich ja andere quellen noch
suchen aber wir haben krankenhausdaten
wir wissen ob die menschen krank waren
oder nicht wie krank sie waren ob sie
gestorben sind wie viele wie viele
falsch codiert worden sind die gar
keinen corona hatten sondern
schenkelhals bruch oder sonst irgendwas
und dann uns gezeigt wurden weil
vielleicht unzulänglichkeiten im
krankenhaus system dazu geführt haben
dass er kommt neu dazu das muss man
sagen also jetzt kommen in die statistik
wahrscheinlich durch durch solche
forderungen und ihnen kommen jetzt die
die zahlen derer die im
krankenhaus liegen mit oder schals bruch
oder sowas um das beispiel mal die
zusätzlich krone haben aber wegen des
oberteils bruches im krankenhaus kriegen
das sind jetzt nicht die meisten ja aber
es sind sehr viele war symptomatisch
weil jetzt jeder getestet wurde am
krankenhaus aber die werden ja in
unseren statistiken geführt ich will
jetzt gar nicht sagen dass der
bürgerwille hinter gesteckt hat aber
wenn sie 70.000 heute im krankenhaus
haben über über zwei jahre die als
corona patienten gerechnet wurden dann
haben wir alle sorge dass da was
passiert und tatsächlich stellen wir
jetzt heute fest die symptomatisch die
hatten alle nix mit krone zu tun aber
die hatten positiven test und was wo zu
mussten sie dann ins krankenhaus weil
sie das an die haben andere sachen
anhalt sagen der oberschenkelhals wo ist
jetzt nur ein ganz kleiner ausschnitt
also vielleicht sollte fressen sich
selbst kurieren zu hause aber
ungefährlich bleiben einfach zu hause
und
vor wir jetzt die experten im
oberschenkelhalsbruch werden gegen ja in
ein ganz ganz kurze pause und dann geht
es hier weiter mit herr larsen und jan
dem intensivbetten schwindel
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren sind für den 8 der schlagzeilen
machen mein name fehler
so nicht über chat bürger hätten das
auto aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darm führen hoch trafen
die debatten über die rettung des
weltklimas und um die füße russland die
ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig um
es nur der afg zu überlassen lasst den
leuten noch mal den spaß wir sehen da
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
politik bei den journalisten ihren job
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
zu finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig gut
das vorliegen eines party zum manko
vielleicht einmal konnten wir ganz
nennen noch ist und welche anderen
träger aus
das bringt mich hat mein beifahrer meine
sache immer bekommt er kümmert sich
darum niemand ist
man muss ja ganz knapp drüber sprechen
gastein sagt nicht der hat mich richtig
ist die komödie nicht begraben nur noch
viertel noch
[Musik]
hier ging es auch in der pause sehr
lebendig weiter und wir machen jetzt
direkt weiter mit tom larsen und seinem
intensiven schwindel ja vielen dank also
ich muss dazu sagen dass die gesamte
thematik nicht schon seit anfang der
krise beschäftigt und ich habe mich
gestern gefreut gestern sind endlich
alle daten angekommen viele menschen da
draußen werden wahrscheinlich denken was
daten sind ja nicht aufregend ich finde
das sehr aufregend und ich habe seit
gestern vollständige krankenhausdaten
2009 10 20 und 21 und ich kann sagen es
gibt eigentlich eine gute nachricht und
eine schlechte die damit verbunden ist
die gute nachricht ist es gab nie eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems die
schlechte ist es gab eine unterlassung
des gesundheitssystems das heißt wir
haben uns in 2009/10 19,2 millionen
menschen in den krankenhäusern in
deutschland gehabt mit allen möglichen
verschiedenen diagnosen und krankheiten
2020 waren es schon nur noch 16,7 2021
waren 16,6 das heißt in deutschen
krankenhäusern sind fünf millionen
menschen nicht in die krankenhäuser
gekommen ob sie jetzt verschoben wurden
aber mittlerweile nach zwei jahren wird
man sagen ich glaube die leute wollen
nicht mehr ins krankenhaus und ich
möchte die leute animieren wenn sie
leiden haben gehen sie wieder ins
krankenhaus das ist glaube ich der
richtige zeitpunkt denn mittlerweile ist
es so dass die dass die menschen die in
die intensivstation kommen wo ich will
das jetzt mal einfach mal in einem
zusammenhang setzen in den
intensivstationen wird natürlich auch
geld verdient das sind ja auch
wirtschaftsbetriebe die krankenhäuser
man darf das jetzt irgendwie nicht
übelnehmen auf der einen seite sind sie
für unsere gesundheit auf der anderen
seite verdienen sie geld aber wir sehen
eine zunahme auf den intensivstationen
gerade von pflege geraden und das ist
sehr brisant das müsste eigentlich auch
herr lauterbach untersuchen das ist ja
unser bundesgesundheitsminister das
jetzt ist das nicht geschehen wir wissen
dass 2020 2020 100.000 menschen
zusätzlich auf deutsche intensivstation
kam wo wir alle gedacht haben die wären
voll mit corona patienten und es kam auf
100.000 zusätzliche pflege gerade und
die nummer um beispiel zu 59.000 alleine
waren davon
80 plus also 80 und älter und in pflege
grad 3 4 und 5 die hat man zusätzlich in
2020 in die intensivstation verbracht
und was bedeutet das für die menschen
die menschen haben gedacht die sind voll
die intensivstation und was wird gemacht
es werden 50.000 zusätzliche menschen in
20 20 22 21 über 80 jahre bei
reingeschoben die konsequenzen daraus
die möchte ich eigentlich gar nicht
tiefer beleuchten weil ich mir nur die
zahlen angesehen habe und ich habe
gesagt das ist eine katastrophe das ist
in der tat ein großes problem was wir
seit jahren haben auch bei der
berichterstattung über das
gesundheitssystem dass das
gesundheitssystem ist ein riesengroßes
kosten jonglage system wohl der kunde
der patient ja nicht derjenige ist der
wie beim kauf eines fernsehers sagt ja
den habe ich gelesen stiftung warentest
er ist gut der kunde kann in der regel
gesundheitssystemen nicht einschätzen
was der arzt ihm verordneten wir haben
über generationen von
gesundheitsministern immer das gleiche
problem gehabt das gesundheitssystem
weicht dahin aus wo es am meisten zu
verdienen gibt und das war im falle von
corona eben leider auch eine pauschale
bei der auslastung der intensivstation
liege bei 75 prozent lagen und oh wunder
wenig später waren die krankenhäuser
alle bei etwa 75 prozent da gab es
nämlich diesen bonus obendrauf und das
ist genau das problem was dann wiederum
verzerrt den blick auf die pandemie und
auf die auslastung des
gesundheitssystems und das finde ich ist
hoch dringlich und muss politische
aufgabe sie verkennen ja damit
eigentlich erstmal die lage das ist ja
nichts was ich dem gesundheitssystem
irgendwie an kreide sondern es sind ja
gerichtsentscheidungen es sind leben
geschlossen worden ist denn existenzen
vernichtet worden mit der begründung die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems wäre
ein problem und jetzt sehe ich habe fünf
millionen weniger patienten wie kann ich
ein system mit fünf millionen weniger
patienten überlassen es geht gar nicht
das ist dass man sich jedoch auf die
intensivstation patienten von denen ich
jetzt erstmal sagen würde die waren im
vorjahr nicht da wohl die gleiche anzahl
da war dann ist das nicht überlassen
darum sage ich das muss politisch
aufgearbeitet werden denn die politik
aber dringt die politik weiß welche
anreize setzt und sie weiß auch dass
sich auf der basis dieser zahlen solche
lockdown maßnahmen nicht wirklich
und man sich einmal ganz kurz ein haken
und zwar was ja immer so dass wir immer
freie betten hatten es wurde auch
berichtet ich habe damals immer auf
twitter habe ich mal gepostet die noch
frei war das war auch in der härtesten
seit 12 wenn ich mich richtig erinnere
mit daten sollte man immer vorsichtig
sein aber das eigentliche problem war
jedoch dass einzelne ortschaften einfach
sehr stark betroffen waren und das war
doch immer die angst dass unser
gesundheitssystem zusammenbricht weil
halt ortsbezogen in manchen
krankenhäusern einheit wirklich
überfüllung da war ja aber das ist ja
genau was ich vorhin schon sagen
394.000 menschen werden von deutschen
intensivstationen in 20 20 von einer
intensivstation in ein anderes
krankenhaus verlegt also wenn sie
194.000 verlegung haben also insgesamt
sind da 1,9 millionen patienten gewesen
ein prozent verlegen sie dann ist das
nicht ungewöhnlich dass solche patienten
verlegt das ist eine völlig normale
sache für die krankenhäuser das ist das
ist eingeübt eingespielt das sind jetzt
infektiöse patienten da sind natürlich
besondere dinge zu beachten aber ich
brauche dafür nicht die presse anrufen
und ich brauche schon gleich die
bundeswehr und so also laut ihren daten
gab es keine überbelegung na ja wir
sollten nicht vergessen ich will dass
ich für sie ich habe keinen zugang zu
diesen zahlen also sie wie sie die für
das ist auch gar nicht infrage stellen
am aber die haben sie das haben sie
lange recherchiert und das muss man
ernst nehmen aber genau so ernst muss
man doch auch nehmen dass es viele viele
operationen gab viele auch die auf
intensivstationen hätten kommen sollen
warum der operation durchzuführen auch
dringende operationen krebspatienten als
auch immer die diese option nicht
durchführen konnten weil diese
intensivstationen belastet waren oder
belegt waren oder je nachdem überbelegt
waren mit corona patient und dann frage
ich mich auch das ist nicht das muss ich
dem ort und haben sie gerne können sie
den äckern und zwei ist vielleicht
können sie das dann auch klarstellen
weil das wirklich nachfrage die ich aber
auch wieder leicht an meine
journalistische kollegen es gab immer
die berichte über die situation auf
intensivstationen pflegerinnen und
pfleger die gesagt wir sind die am
anschlag es gab reportagen die durch
verschiedenen klinik flore gegangen
sondern durch bedrückende sachen wo auch
sehr glaubhaft vermittelt worden ist
dass die pflegerinnen und pflegern
wirklich ein höllenjob macht auch
aufgrund der überlastung ließ da gibt
da frage ich sie jetzt weil sie sagen
das gab es alles gar nicht also war das
alles eine fehlinformation die wir
erhalten haben also das gab es alles ich
fange mal hinten an das gab es alles gar
nicht habe ich natürlich nicht gesagt
sondern ich habe gesagt ich habe dass
das kann ich unterstützen es gibt
tatsächlich menschen die auf
intensivstationen arbeiten und dort sich
belastet gewesen belastet gefühlt haben
das ist auch nachvollziehbar weil die
arbeit die auf einer intensivstation
sowieso stattfindet ist immer mit tod
und mit krankheit verbunden das ist in
der intensivstation so ich kenne das
selber ich habe eine woche mal eine
intensivstation besucht aber als
besucher eines patienten also ich habe
meine schicht sozusagen mitgemacht und
kann das sagen wie das da abläuft das
sind tolle menschen auf den
intensivstationen das müssen die auch
dort sein wir haben eine zusatzbelastung
die müssen sich ein kittel müssten
teilweise schwitzen bestimmte arbeiten
machen das ist aber für die ganz normal
na ja da muss ich mal widersprechen wenn
man sich diese reportagen im anschaut
für die kollegen bei bild haben da auch
reportagen und macht aber es gab eine
sehr eindrucksvolle
insbesondere im rbb wurde die glaub ich
dargestellt und da wenn man dort den
pflegern zuhört dann sagen sie das
corona intensivpatienten eben nicht wie
alle anderen patienten sind denn sie
müssen selbst in schutzanzügen arbeiten
was wahnsinnig anstrengend ist für die
pflege was ich sagte ja genau ja und
gleichzeitig ist sozusagen ein crooner
intensiv patient wesentlich braucht noch
mehr arbeit als ich nenne man normale
intensivpatienten und der eindruck der
sich dort ergeben hat dass es zumindest
regional eine viel zu hohe belastung in
den intensivstationen für diese
pflegerinnen und pfleger gab ihr habt
gesagt wir können unsere arbeit
teilweise nicht mehr machen dafür ist ja
die verlegung da das ist ja das was
sozusagen auch gemacht wurde aber ich
musste natürlich zurück zu meinen daten
ich habe jetzt natürlich ein paar sachen
gesagt wo ich sagen okay ich war auch
nicht in jeder intensiv stadt so was ich
eigentlich sagen wollte ist auch der
professor marx vom nie wieder präsident
und auch die sämtlichen köpfe vom tv die
haben sich ja auch geäußert zur bundes
notbremse ist ja gesagt worden wir sind
überlastet und so weiter das problem
auch lauter war hat sich übrigens dazu
geäußert er hat ja gesagt jetzt liegen
die 47 48 jährige väter auf denen sind
und die kinder verlieren ihre eltern
ich will denen das glauben das problem
ist nur die hohlen einzelne
liegen bekannte meinung ein ich besorge
mir daten von 1260 krankenhäusern von
1350 intensivstation das heißt also ich
gucke da jetzt nicht mit irgendwelchen
emotionen drauf oder sonst irgendwas
sondern ich sehe einfach nur die daten
und wie dort gearbeitet wird wie die
auslastung prozentual war und so weiter
und ja natürlich ist sind es gibt
intensivstationen die fahnen permanent
auf 100 prozent da ist immer feuer das
immer feuer und es gibt
intensivstationen die achten da nicht
drauf die fahren auch mit 50 wir müssen
auch hochfahren der intensivstation ist
das vielleicht man einmal ganz kurz
sagen eine intensivstation ist ja etwas
wo patienten in der schwersten notlage
sozusagen liegen müssen da brauchen sie
ganz viel apparate und die müssen
funktionieren und wenn sie sozusagen
schon zehn oder 20 betten haben und sie
haben da maschinen dann müssen sie auch
techniker in der nähe haben sie müssen
auch bezahlt werden und sie haben da
nicht 124 oder 125 sondern sie haben
eins zu zwei patienten also ein pfleger
zwei patienten das ist alles teuer das
heißt sie müssen hochfahren es geht gar
nicht anders also wer uns sagt ja da
sind nur noch 20 prozent frei auf der
intensivstation der guckt sich nicht die
lage an das ist für die normale das
müssen wir machen und das ist auch nicht
irgendwie eine krankheit des
gesundheitssystems viele maschinen viel
personal viel techniker kostet geld dann
müssen diese these zusammengefasst ist
eigentlich es war schon immer schlimmer
auf derartige station ganz genau wo ich
nur als mathematisch mittel begabter
ausgestiegen bin war die tatsache dass
wir zu anfang der pandemie von herrn
spahn gehört haben wir haben 28.000
intensivbetten in deutschland zu einem
irgendwie anderen zeitpunkt mitten drin
mal hieß es dann ja menschen haben
22.000 intensivbetten und davon sind
hallo wo sind denn die anderen also wenn
mir jemand eine prozentuale auslastung
mitteilt aber sich die bezugsgröße
zwischendurch ändert dann brauche ich
wenigstens eine begründung warum sich
die bezugsgröße geändert hat und das
konnte in der regel die politik nicht
liefern das nimmt man einfach so hin als
nachrichten konsument aber es ist
einfach nicht logisch das habe ich
beschrieben 100 landkreise von 400 in
deutschland haben quasi ich sag mal
relativ trickreich ihre intensivbetten
abgemeldet die sie hatten das ist eine
definitionssache das haben aber nur 100
von 400 gemacht das heißt also ein
kleiner teil also möglicherweise haben
die anderen 300 ist nicht verstanden
dass man das so machen hätte können und
dafür haben sie dann ausgleichszahlung
bekommen also da sind wir wieder bei
ihrer eingangs these ich finde ich finde
eine sache hoch interessant bzw wichtig
auch was reif sagt es gibt so viele
fragezeichen wenn sie schon bestätigt
wohnanlage 2000 anlagen doch sagen wir
brauchen endlich eine aufarbeitung des
gestern also als untersuchungsausschuss
möglicherweise der hervorbringt was dort
zu welchem zeichnung ehrlich gesagt er
öffentlich war welche daten es gab was
politiker dazu gesagt haben und ich
glaube keine krise hat die bevölkerung
je so eingenommen so
eingeschnitten und darüber wird viel zu
wenig gesprochen findet ja vielleicht
dass der spruch von jens spahn wir
werden uns für vieles entschuldigen
müssen
wird daraus wir werden uns für vieles
entschuldigen müssen wir noch mehr also
ich bin auch sehr gespannt hochwertig
lesen ich bin gespannt dementsprechend
soviel eigentlichkeit an diesem tisch
das ist ja schon fast ein bisschen
langweilig deswegen ging es weiter zu
ja ganz anderes thema wer will wer will
wer hat noch nicht moral ist derzeit
wieder ganz groß im sommerschlussverkauf
alles muss raus denn wir haben olympia
und alle welt die menschenrechts
organisationen weisen jetzt auch die
schlimme menschenrechtslage in china hin
da haben sie recht das ist auch schlimm
nur es war eigentlich schon immer
schlimm die bundesregierung fährt auch
nicht nach china zu den olympischen
winterspielen und wird keine
staatssekretärs delegation geben die
fährt dann erst wieder hinterher da hin
und macht einen offiziellen
arbeitsbesuch jetzt zu den olympischen
spielen gibt es das nicht und mir kann
keiner so richtig erklären warum
ist eigentlich die hohe moral immer bei
den sportveranstaltungen da und da muss
boykottiert werden da muss man mehr
wegbleiben und hinterher fährt man zum
ganz normalen arbeitsbesuch und macht
wieder geschäfte wir alle tragen made in
china irgendwelche masken nehmt nutzen
die testkits wir haben die t-shirts an
vw hat einen riesenberg in der
inkriminierten uiguren regionen chinas
tibet geht es schon immer schlecht
hongkong
verschlechtert sich die
menschenrechtslage auch ständig aber
wenn es um olympia gibt dann gibt es die
ganz großen boykott forderung der
milliardär und großinvestor george soros
hat sogar die olympischen spiele 1936
verglichen das finde ich einen gewagten
vergleich ich kenne nicht den anteil des
china geschäfts am vermögen von herrn
schorr roche muss mich aber einfach
wundern warum wird dieses thema immer
aufgemacht wenn es um sport geht und
nicht wenn es um die ganz normalen
geschäfte geht die wir ständig dort ab
schießt das kann mir keiner erklären wir
müssen uns endlich mal entscheiden ist
sport eigentlich völkerverständigung
oder ist es diktatoren deko wenn es
letzteres ist dann müssen wir es lassen
ansonsten reisen auch unsere sportler
als botschafter des beim essen sein und
haben die gleichen chancen für unser
system zu werben für die freie welt zu
werben für die feinen ideen und die
freien meinung zu werben und ich bin da
nicht bange dass uns das auch gelingen
wird
reife das kann mir ja genauso
unterstützen noch weiter weiterführen
also ich meine bei einer werte basierten
außenpolitik durch vw erwähnt wir
könnten genauso mercedes erwähnen
mercedes hat im letzten jahr mehr autos
verkauft in china als im ganzen rest der
welt mercedes hauptwerk oder und auch
die konzernzentrale in stuttgart
stuttgart ist der sitz der baden
württembergischen landesregierung die
wird angeführt von herr kretschmann der
grüne ministerpräsident der einzige
bisher der könnte doch jeden tag dorthin
gehen ins werk und zum
vorstandsvorsitzenden und sagen freunde
nicht mit mir und alle möglichen
bestimmungen ins werk setzen zusammen
mit frau berbalk dass das aufhört ich
habe vor mehr als zehn jahren auf dem
münchner marienplatz gestanden und
demonstriert für die olympischen spiele
in münchen und in garmisch partenkirchen
mit kati witt war ganz geehrt daneben
wir stehen zu dürfen und vielen anderen
sportlern hintergrund war dass das
unternehmen für der sich damals
gearbeitet hatte olympia sponsor war und
der
ja die die wolken gerne alle zusammen
erreichen dass die olympischen spiele
nach münchen kommen geleitet wurde das
deutsche olympische komitee damals von
einem grünen michael vesper der
versprochen hatte nachhaltigkeit zu
bringen in dieser olympischen spiele und
nachhaltige ideen und die ersten grünen
spiele daraus zu machen trotzdem hat die
bevölkerung in münchen in garmisch und
in zwei anderen landkreisen mehrheitlich
und in jedem landkreis abgelehnt dass
diese spiele da hinkommen wollen wenig
bausünden verkehr so ein dreck wollen
wir gar nicht haben umwelt verpesten das
waren die gründe warum diese olympischen
spiele nicht in deutschland stattfinden
und china hat ja gesagt wir sehen das
gleich mit den olympischen spielen 20 26
und den kommenden wo es auch solche
auseinandersetzung gegeben hat und die
bevölkerung gesagt haben in manchen
ländern das wollen wir nicht haben also
wer sich hier beschwert soll am ende
nicht sagen warum gibt es nicht bei uns
oder zu unseren zu unseren umständen
oder in unseren gefilden den nicht sagt
wir sind bereit so was auch durch aber
ich finde eine sache interessant bei
dieser freiheit des boykotts dass in den
usa das anders als in europa gelingt
zumindest eine einigkeit herzustellen
dass man eben diese spiele boykottiert
und jetzt würde ich nicht sagen dass es
den usa wirtschaftlich wahnsinnig
schlechter geht oder sie sozusagen unter
der werte basierten außenpolitik der
vergangenen jahrzehnte gelitten haben im
gegenteil die usa sagen jetzt wir müssen
unsere wirtschaft auch deshalb in den
usa wieder stärken zum beispiel die
chip-produktion die massiv ausgebaut
wird auch in den usa und ich finde es
problematisch insbesondere bei den
grünen in diesen tagen dass wir da vor
der wahl ganz ganz viel gehört haben die
armen menschen in hongkong was da in
taiwan passiert was der präsident china
das tut und natürlich würde müssten wir
müssen wir müssen und davon hört man
plötzlich gar nichts mehr also natürlich
hat frau bianca führt zu tun jetzt mit
der russlandkrise ich weiß nicht wie
viel einfluss die dann tatsächlich
wirklich hart aber was jetzt die china
politik angeht was hongkong angeht da
habe ich noch gar nichts gehört ich war
viele viele jahre in hongkong habt da
viele aktivisten immer wieder berichtet
seit 2004 10 viele aktiviert getroffen
georgia brown den haben wir mal hier
nach deutschland geholt da gab es riesen
erlahmt dann direkt von der chinesischen
regierung dass das in die hand
geschüttelt hat und aber vor allem die
grünen waren hinterher und haben gesagt
wir müssen denen helfen die sind jetzt
hinter gittern seitdem sie der regierung
sind höre ich nichts mehr die grünen
haben wir jede menge betätigungsfeld sie
können beispielsweise wie es übrigens
die kanzlerin mal gemacht hat den dalai
lama empfangen dann viel spaß hinterher
mit den reaktionen aus china das wäre
aber mutig sie können auch mal ein
zeichen setzen und die taipeh vertretung
von taiwan besuchen wo es im augenblick
ziemlich brenzlig ist da kann man schon
ganz gut statuen zeigen warum das immer
beim sport ist wo es eigentlich nichts
kostet das habe ich nie so richtig
verstanden ich hab den berg kräftige
meisten von uns nicht bewusst erlebt so
jetzt haben wir zwei mal 1980 die
sowjetunion die damals in afghanistan
einmarschiert ist an gab es ein boykott
das fest nicht kennen jemanden hat sich
der da hätte laufen sollen vom deutschen
team mittelstreckenläufer konnte er
nicht das war seine einzige richtige
chance und das eine medaille zu gewinnen
also insofern leider vergebens und dann
1984 die reaktion ist damaligen
ostblocks die olympischen spiele in los
angeles geht dann eben von der seite als
quid pro quo auch boykottiert worden
waren zwar auch tolle spiele das
entscheidet es aber trotzdem es bringt
ja überhaupt nicht und ganz im gegenteil
eigentlich ist der olympische geist auch
in krisen zusammenzukommen und krisen zu
überwinden durch das zusammenkommen
deswegen kann ich auch diesen boykott
nicht als goldene idee nachvollziehen im
gegenteil man muss ja auch einfach mal
eine sache sagen es gibt ja auch sachen
die china durchaus sehr gut gemacht hat
also gerade ich muss das thema corona
ihren bezahlen nochmal einmal einbringen
gerade in kronach fragen heute morgen
mal geguckt also china hat 1,7
milliarden einwohner 1,2 1,4 sogar und
die haben 106000 kroner infektion gehabt
und nur 4600 menschen sind gestorben
jährlich die statistiken sind und was da
im labor wirklich passiert ist haben sie
nie schlechter als bei uns hier in
deutschland also ich glaube zumindest
wenn sie sehr viel negativer werden wäre
die möglichkeit größer dass in china die
statistiken doch etwas anders
dargestellt werden ja aber ich finde es
interessant wie das denn die oft die
werden ja offiziell geführt ich könnte
mir meine eigenen gedanken dazu machen
ganz klar aber ich finde das schon
beeindruckend und das sollte man einfach
mal erwähnt also ich weiß nicht was die
gemacht haben wir haben ja damals diesen
super lock down gesehen wo wir alle im
fernsehen geguckt haben usw fanden wir
es jetzt gut oder fanden wir es schlecht
ich glaube wir fanden so schlecht aber
so ähnliches zeug haben wir dann hier
auch gekriegt und wir haben aber 100
13.000 menschen die das muss ja auch mal
jemand erklären warum es bei uns so
schlecht gelaufen ist oder ist es bei
denen auch schlecht gelaufen wir gehen
jetzt nicht noch einmal ganz groß
zurückzuholen also viel zeit haben wir
nicht mehr so abschließendes plädoyer
von der aif wir sollten es nicht
boykottieren ich finde man sollte
hingehen man sollte darüber reden und
bei jedem normalen staatsbesuch kriegen
wir von china demonstriert dass sie am
längeren hebel sitzen bei jedem
staatsbesuchen ich bin oft mit merkel
dort gewesen gibt es abends einen
empfang in der botschaft jedes mal
werden dissidenten eingeladen und jedes
mal können die leider nicht kommen weil
jemand vor ihrer tür steht und ihnen
empfiehlt nicht dorthin zu gehen und das
empfiehlt er sehr nachdrücklich das
lassen wir uns jedes mal gefallen also
wenn schon dann keinen gratis mut bei
sport sondern mut im alltag und mut eben
auch bei geschäften wo es wehtut ich
finde das war ein sehr schönes
schlussplädoyer für unsere sendung heute
abend herzlichen dank dass sie
zugeschaut haben ganz ganz lieben dank
an meine gäste tom larsen ralf schuler
paar holzhammer und béla anda und da ich
auch autorin zeige ich doch noch mal das
buch schauen sie sich mal an schönen
abend noch und wenn sie mögen
dienstagabend sehen wir uns wieder
[Musik]